نعود ونذكر بالاخبار العاجله التي نقلناها
قبل قليل نقلا عن سي ان ان عن مسؤول
امريكي بان الضربات الجديده في اليمن
استهدفت منشاه رادار يستخدمها الحوثيون
وبان الضربات الجديده ضد الحوثيين في
اليمن اقل نطاقا بكثير من تلك السابقه
وبان القوات الامريكيه نفذت الضربات
الجديده ضد اهداف للحوثيين في اليمن بشكل
منفرد حول سياق ما جرى ينضم الينا الان من
واشنطن مراسل الجزيره ناصر الحسيني الذي
يتابع لنا ما جرى ما الذي حدث اذا ما الذي
يقوله الامريكيون حول هذه
العمليه لا يعطي الامريكيون في هذه اللحظه
الكثير من التفاصيل كما تفضلت هي ضربه
واحده على ما يبدو ل نح نحن لسنا امام
هجوم كبير بعد من عده منصات سواء من
الغواصات او الطائرات يبدو انها ضربه
محدوده كما يقول الامريكيون متناسبه مع
الخطر الذي يمثله انصار الله الحوثيون حسب
هذا المسؤول الذي يتحدث دون ان يقول من هو
يعلن عن حويته لكن تسريب سريع في وقت
متاخر هنا في واشنطن لوسائل الاعلام من
بينها سينان ان هذه الضربه الامريكيه
الجديده لم يقل لماذا ولكن يبدو انها ضربه
جد محدوده استهدفت منطقه رادار او منشاه
للرادار في منطقه
الحديديه حسب ما هذا المسؤول الامريكي
ويقول ايضا ان هذه العمليه لم تكن عمليه
عسكريه الكبيره كما شاهدنا امس وانما
عمليه محدوده بضربه موجهه يبدو ان
الولايات المتحده مصره على ان تلقن على ما
يبدو الجانب الحوثي درسا عسكريا الولايات
المتحده في كافه تصريحات مسؤولين اليوم
اكدت هنا وهناك في البنتاغون وعلى المستوى
السياسي ان الولايات المتحده بصدد مراقبه
الوضع ان كثب في انتظار اي رد فعل عسكري
من طرف الجانب اليمني من طرف انصار الله
الحوثيين وهم يتوقعون هذا الرد العس عسكري
في اي لحظه وبالتالي يبدو ان هذه الضربه
الامريكيه استباقيه تحذيريه كي لا يقوم او
ينجر الجانب الطرف الجانب الاخر الحوثي
الى تنفيذ تهديداته
واستهداف بحريه امريكيه او مصالح امريكيه
في المنطقه يمكن اعتبار هذه الضربه
استباقيه تحذيريه مازالت الولايات المتحده
تؤكد على رئاس رئيس بايدن وغيره من
المسؤولين بان الولايات المتحده لا تسعى
وان دخلت في هذه المعركه مع الجانب الحوثي
فهي لا تسعى لتوسعه نطاق الحرب الحاليه
الدائره على غزه وتريد ضربه محدوده لافها
الجانب اليمني بانه لا مصلحه له في التدخل
لكن البريطانيون او الامريكيون يعلنون
ايضا للراي العام الامريكي عبر مختلف
وسائل الاعلام وتصريحات من بايدن الى
اخرين بان الولايات متحده مستعده
للاستمرار في هذه اللعبه العسكريه اذا ما
تطلب الامر ذلك اذا استمر ورا هذا التهديد
المسلح المباشر من طرف انصار الله
الحوثيين على على الملاحه البحريه هناك سو
اذا هناك استعداد امريكي لمواصله هذه
اللعبه العسكريه في هذه اللحظه ضربات
امريكيه محدوده
ومتناسب تسعى كثيرا للابتعاد عن الجانب
المدني تسعى لتقويض القدرات العسكريه
للجانب اليمني اكثر من الاضرار به في
الارواح تسعى للعتاد على ما يبدو في هذه
اللحظه في هذه المرحله من هذا الصراع وقال
هذا المسؤول بطبيعه الحال ان العمليه
العسكريه لم تكن ذات نطاق واسع وبالتالي
رساله تحذيريه مره اخرى لليوم الثاني او
لليله الثانيه على التوالي لجانب الحوثي
من واشنطن والرئيس بايدن اعطى الضوء
الاخضر امس اليوم ايضا اكد في تصريحاته
بانه يعتبر الجانب الحوثي حركه ارهابيه مع
تعبيره عن القلق بشان الاسواق اسواق النفط
والملاحه ولكن الولايات المتحده مره اخرى
تؤكد بشكل او باخر بانها مستعده للاستمرار
في هذه المجازفه العسكريه ان صح التعبير